and this is the
key distinction that i think people
don't realize it's you know
that oftentimes when you talk about
autonomous vehicles
you're there's often a driver in the
seat that's ready
to uh to take over uh what's called a
safety driver
and then waymo is really one of the
only companies that i'm aware of or at
least as like boldly and
carefully and all and all that is
actually has
cases and now we'll talk about more and
more where there's
literally no driver so that that's
another
the interesting case of where the driver
is not supposed to disengage that's like
a
nice middle ground they're still there
but they're not supposed to disengage
but really there's the case when there's
no
okay there's something magical about
there being nobody in the driver's seat
like just like to me you mentioned um
the first time you wrote some code for
free space navigation of the parking lot
that was like a magical moment
to me just sort of an as an observer of
robots
the first magical moment is seeing
an autonomous vehicle turn like make a
left turn
like apply sufficient torque
to the steering wheel to where like
there's a lot of rotation
and for some reason and there's nobody
in the driver's seat
for some reason that that communicates
that here's a being with power
that makes a decision there's something
about like the steering wheel because
we perhaps romanticize the notion of the
steering wheel it's so essential to the
our conception
our 20th century conception of a car and
it
turning the steering wheel with nobody
in driver's seat
that to me i think maybe to others
it's really powerful like this thing is
in control
and then there's this leap of trust that
you give like i'm going to put my life
in the hands of this thing that's in
control so in that sense
when there's no but no driver in the
driver's seat that's a magical moment
for robots so i i'm i gotten a chance to
uh last year to take a ride
in a waymo vehicle and that that was the
magical moment there's like
nobody in the driver's seat it's it's
like the little details you would think
it doesn't matter whether it's a driver
or not but like if
there's no driver and the steering wheel
is turning on its own
i don't know that's magical it's
absolutely magical like i
you've taken many of these rights in a
completely empty car
no human in the car pulls up you know
you call it on your cell phone it pulls
up
you get in it takes you on its way
there's nobody
uh in the car but you right that's
something called you know fully
driverless
or uh rider only uh mode of operation
uh yeah it it is
magical it is uh transformative this is
what we hear from our
writers it kind of really changes your
experience and not like that that really
is what unlocks the real potential of
this technology
you